dirigeants politiques nous promettent de
réseau dans les principaux conflits nous
essaierons jacqueline baudrier de faire
de la radio de la bonne radio vous avez
la responsabilité de faire exister de
faire vivre et d'assurer le
fonctionnement le développement de radio
france
vous avez officiellement lancé sur les
ondes
cette nuit à minuit exactement et en
direct sous les projecteurs et flashs
radio france vos impressions la mi
journée mais je pense que nous avons
fait le meilleur départ possible c'est
toujours difficile au départ avec de
nouveaux programmes
il faut donner de france inter et de
radio france qui se compose quel
privilège de ce composé de quatre
programmes une idée dynamique unis des
riches il faut surtout respecter notre
public et ce privilège c'est précisément
d'avoir quatre programmes différents
france inter france culture france
musique fip sans oublier la radio
extérieur nous sommes entendus comme
vous savez en afrique à madagascar et
l'on peut faire en ce moment un petit
signe d'amitié à tous ses auditeurs
lointain qui sont extrêmement fidèle
donc il faut que nous pensions à tous
ses auditeurs et la richesse de ses
quatre programmes nous permet justement
d'avoir une radio à quatre claviers
vous allez parler à plusieurs reprises
de rechercher avec ceux qui vont être
vos collaborateurs
une écriture nouvelle par le chant ou le
sens la signification à la télévision on
parle beaucoup d'écriture par l'image et
c'était un idéal n'est ce pas pour
chaque créateur de télévision de faire
une dramatique en écrivant avec l'image
nous nous sommes le royaume du son il
faut écrire avec le son je veux dire par
là qu'il faut faire des recherches qu'il
faut s'interroger sur ce que le son peut
apporter le son c'est le royaume de
l'imaginaire et je crois qu'il y à là en
effet source de réflexion permanente
parce que la radio de toute façon est à
un tournant décisif de son histoire
elle doit chercher des voies nouvelles
ce ne sera pas facile mais c'est une
tâche extrêmement passionnant et nous y
attachons tous tellement d'importance
que j'ai même créé un bureau de
prospective qui est dirigée par françois
billetdoux est naturellement tous les
tous ceux qui s'intéressent à ces
problèmes
les intérêts sont ou seront associés aux
travaux de ce bureau d'études a commencé
par les principaux responsables de nos
programmes vous souhaitez avec vos
principaux collaborateurs réaliser une
entreprise pilote exemplaire à la fois à
l'intérieur et à l'extérieur et ce n'est
pas trop optimistes écoutez j'espère que
non puisque nous sommes tous animés par
beaucoup de fois et d' enthousiasme une
entreprise pilote exemplaire je voudrais
qu'elle le soit sur le plan humain et
social nos auditeurs comme nos
téléspectateurs ont évidemment supporter
les conséquences des soubresauts de
l'agonie de la rtf essayons de donner
une âme à notre nouvelle société qui
radio france en faisant une information
à l'intérieur de l'entreprise
une information complète quotidienne et
en même temps en établissant dialogue
cette maison je la connais bien la radio
la télévision je sais qu'il y à peu
d'entreprises dans notre pays peut être
dans le monde où il ya tant d'hommes et
de femmes qui aiment leur métier avec la
passion qu'ils manifestent et c'est
peut-être à cause de cette passion qu'il
y a par moment les crises que nous
connaissons et que nous subissons écoles
publiques et la subit avec nous